let's take a look at how to add adds to
your site in order to serve ads on your
site you'll need an account with one of
the ex providers we will use adsense
account for our demo we choose to show
you how to create responsive ed units
because you are building a responsive
site right so use responsive ad units
responsive ads automatically resize
based on the size of the device and the
width of the prior container this will
ensure that the edge works in line with
your responsive layout and the site will
look great on any device so first step
we're opening the homepage of Adsense
and clicking on my ads then we'll click
on new head unit and we'll give it a
name for our purpose will call it demo 2
we're choosing the responsive size like
we said before and then we have the
option to choose the type let's go with
the default here then we could choose
the style I like this one and of course
you could do here the best to match the
theme of your site and then we're just
clicking save and get the code now all
you need to do is just to copy and paste
this inline code to your HTML